- 'Don't you judge me.'
- 'No, we don't judge--'
- Don't you judge me.
- Then don't call us.
- Then don't call for help.
- I had to. I'm in pain.
- Andrew!
- I'm in so much pain!
Andrew, if you don't
wanna be judged
don't call
the Sheriff's Department.
Look, look, look.
It is not my finest hour.
Are you stuck in...
...side or under?
A little bit of all that.
Can I ask you a question
man to man?
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
And I don't know her
very well.
Are you going in the front
or the back?
'Cause I can't honestly--
Right now, I'm doing the front
'cause I already--
I sort of messed up
the back already.
[exhales]
Sort of messed up the back.
Oh, I'm getting judged
so completely!
Kids at home,
if you're watching, uh...
There's a whole lot
of predicaments in the world
you can get out of
with a simple understanding
of some physics
and some chemistry.
So what you're gonna do,
wipe.
- Okay, warm.
- Hot, hot, hot.
Reach around.
And you're gonna
cup her lady parts.
I'll give her
the old reach-around.
Yeah. Get real, real,
real, real super hot.
And now, I'm gonna come
in cold on your manhood.
- Right, right.
- You ready?
- Okay. Ready?
- Okay.
22, 42, 32!
Hut!
Hike!
[screams]
[breathing heavily]
[screaming in pain]
Hang on. She's giving.
She's giving. She's giving.
[screaming]
She just kneed me
in the face.
- Okay, I got her.
- She kneed me in the face.
- I got her. I got her.
- Okay.
Alright. How you feeling?
Alright?
Yeah, it's good
seeing you guys.
- Good seeing you, too, man.
- Yeah.